how did you feel when Kauai left there
was like 20 more shots on the tables I'm
like this I'm like what's up
this is serge ibaka taking aim at food
chef and welcome to um where are you
today
I will be cooking for my brother Pascal
second take a a spicy last time
commercial super fun the you know a
movie I made in a kinda classic with a
twist
poutine with fish I okay see me
[Music]
first step I gotta cut the head oh let's
go nice if you know for the chef you
know what you like
salt and pepper omitting salt and pepper
that's a now you have to know how to put
it that's the difference so the base of
poutine is Fred fries so easy nice at
the top of fries now we're gonna do some
gravy
I just don't know insert and cook so I'm
not trying to get sick my team needs me
oh yeah make sure I know they are okay
once you see Pascale face when he's
gonna see the fish eye you don't know
what I'm cooking I'm sure he's gonna
enjoy it
are you doing that space feeder building
man the new Richmond congrats for a new
contractor Thank You Man I appreciate it
do you do you know we still wait for
dinner why team dinner right yeah yeah
the money is not kicking in on no we
gotta wait for the money to kick it did
you sign yet no I did no it's yours
so how's life bro life is good life is
good I definitely a little bit more
recognition you know getting on the
streets I go to LA you usually allow
used to be my spot where I used to go
and be like nobody bothers me because
everyone is Hollywood like it but you
know like getting to LA didn't get any
recognition there it was kind of like a
big deal just like to show you that a
man like you here not you know so one
thing I know for sure is now you cannot
go back in Africa now yeah I'm sure the
news was all over the places when you
sign your call you back cousins I mean
you know you know I this yes you have
about hundred cousins yeah and as you
know like everyone is calling you even
people that you never saw before never
met them but yeah yeah it's family the
whole African cook like continent now
y'all family
I was growing up and coming with man
when you was young it was great I think
growing up my family you know got a big
family three brothers two sisters we was
kind of like in the middle class type my
dad had a good job my mom had a job and
you know they kind of made sure that you
went to school and you know obviously
it's a Catholic school so like you're
supposed to be somebody say and they say
ask about try to go work for God
I got say no go play basketball that was
funny you know I I didn't go to school
to be a priest it's like the minor
seminary and then there's like I went to
the minor seminary which is like it's
like high school and middle school
basically I was like you you ask no no
you know I just don't think it was my
calling you know and and and it wasn't
something that I was supposed to do and
and you know I'm definitely happy what
I'm doing now God knows you might right
yeah he knew exactly do you say that
Pascal don't work for me go play
basketball I did how did you feel about
winning the Most Improved Player
why should I think winning Most Improved
Player was it was cool it's cool moment
going there with my family and and be
able to accept the world yeah it
definitely meant a lot to me so your
next call you tried to go for the NDP
you I'm trying to be the best way I can
be I'm trying to be the best Pascal cam
I can be and I think the best
backgrounds can happen is yet to come
and there's there's a lot more than I
can achieve so you know why not I think
you can do it thank you if you say that
you keep bullying and I will keep
winning right why not
that's all I always always felt like it
or not yeah if you if you all right how
do you feel when I left um I think for
me I remember well was like I was I was
eating my Asian stuff and like I wasn't
surprised like yeah I think we knew that
there was a possibility for him to leave
like he wasn't like expecting to come
back with moved on and and and for me I
mean it was more opportunity for me so I
was like question for you
like how the life changed now since you
become the number one option and achieve
um I don't think it's changed much I
think I'm still the same I mean
obviously you can like you see the walk
ha right always and that's mom that's my
motto it's like humble hustle like it's
us and and I think the humble part of it
is just like reminding myself that you
know where I come from and then the
hustle part of it is just continue to
work hard no matter what no change right
because they think you can take you are
here today and tomorrow go down it I'm
says so she still who you are that's
what I'm doing that's good you say that
can we win dumb money wanna keep kicking
the same person when that's not coming
every every month was moving to the
state at six year or you know feel like
I want to boarding school so I was kind
of used to being away from my family but
then obviously the culture is different
the food is different it's kind of same
similar to me when I moved to Spain when
I was like 16 - right right now so my
focus was I'm here how to make this work
here and he didn't do you miss your
family bit but you so motivated to do
things that's such a quiet oh yeah I was
16 year but a you got no trace right mmm
tell me about your dad influenced in
your life even in your career and
basketball my you know it plays a big
part in what what I become as a
basketball player and and me losing him
kind of like make my basketball career
too kinda different turn just in terms
of like focus and it just wasn't about
wins or losses it was about you know
making my dad proud so like that that
was something that gave me time like an
edge
did you see you play never got to see me
play so something that you know kind of
like still hurts me from you know now
and just knowing that and I would never
get out opportunity I lost my mom when I
was 17 so when things to start going
well and you're like
dan-yi like wow I wish my mom was here
to enjoy this woman with me and say so
it's kind of those moment back a I'm
sure wherever you know your your dad or
my mom
DiPaola so appreciate oh man thank you
thank you it's my I had a good come for
you guys nothing crazy
I'm didn't come to how long were you the
car can be who's the finish the guy on
each on achieve - younger feeling man oh
man I think there's a lot of people on
the team no wow do you know his nickname
ready Freddie no what is it
chapel who is a chapel yeah he says
chapel I'm sorry Freddie
chapel yeah like El Chapo or like a
chapel but chapel because he's sure so
wake up from that's why they call him
Chapel is like you know you know okay so
I'm on this show and they say your name
is chapo your nickname
you see that's it concerns you answers I
mean I'm Charlotte because it's English
at all you know like this is the notes
up so I'd to make sure like I get I get
the rule to be able to call you later
all right
I didn't know
[Laughter]
who's your favorite player all the time
from our generation you know like when I
stopped in basketball this the person I
used to watch the lavas Kevin Durant
you always wear his sneakers so that's
the reason why no that's not why I just
me we just had to find a shootout
comfortable for me and I like low tops
cuz I feel like I was for like a gory I
know you're big mijita big men shoes and
stuff yeah you wear the hypo dunks and I
like you know feeling like a guard and I
don't like the low low top that's why I
didn't really like the co because they
were too low for me started fine like
something I was in between and I think
this was the best for me but but Cadiz
is like one my favorite player is mature
how did you get the name a spicy I used
to watch some youtubers and also there's
a guy named Clarence and you used to say
spicy a lot so I used to say I said it
to like just like on Instagram at some
time like yo like this moves spicy yeah
so like and then I guess people just
added the P on it like spicy P but I I
mean it worked not really a big fan of
it but I'm trying to choose right across
F P skills P skills yeah okay our
University
what no comment no comment no no comment
what do you see was the t can I drink
the cricket cigarette drink eaten smelly
drink exactly I'm you know make it take
- yeah okay anytime you don't own Sur
you take a shot you gonna drink was the
quicker cleavage just give me the right
now oh you're not doing the tea okay you
don't
wait you hope your tea I'll give you a
tea
- you're gonna do the tea I'm gonna give
it a teach three okay don't me the tea
you're a bit cool you let's be cool then
do you have more crickets oh man like no
no show you
he go hey go you're at the cool got the
cool today you only know how works I
wanna ask questions you don't answer you
do not see what was was Yoko
I love duty I'm gonna ask the questions
alright now we're asking your spice
equation you ready
Pascal second spicy man what took you so
long to say you another machine I always
try to be funny
so yeah all right who's your favorite
Akash I don't think about going your
phone no my phone I don't think I have
one
you know you like I'm next time I look
room you're gonna you're gonna start
talking about celebrity mmm-hmm I will
now record that if you can find that I
got you're not gonna get one okay
it's nice the question not working right
now it's not working oh this one reward
because this one you just give me one
okay and if you don't give me and you
drink wait
if I ask the question satisfy see were a
little more spicy and patience
well you gotta stop dude nobody's
drinking you do need that
who is your favorite Franco Kahlo or
Freddie I'm gonna buy this time I say I
need one name
[Applause]
do you like do people actually drink
this like yeah you like a drink
yeah you think you know me I purchase
more wine I know I know exactly so
there's my finger like I'm not trying I
love doing this that's the game we know
that it's not easy that's a cold spicy
like you you say special right you too
spicy
right okay you guys make sure I'm funny
I'm finally sleep all right you guys
make sure when this air that you guys
show how difficult this was it was a
really difficult process
cuz cow most supports multiple all-star
you know every rookie year man used to
dine you know a lot of times to pascals
young man's crazy Fred vanvleet came up
together my man Ricky together
I mean dynamic duo going on right now
this was really hard how friendly this
was really hard and um I'm just not
trying to drink if that's the only
reason I'm choosing somebody and my
answer is I'm gonna go with I'm angry
yeah Wow I love both of them but like if
I have to choose because we don't spice
the game so it's like the question and
Kyle I love you and this is just a show
that's the only reason he's sure you
bring the honesty of people whatever you
say that's how I feel killer
you see I'm yet pretty firm we still got
a lot of time I'm not opposed to spam
you saying you guys
you see you said Freddie that's messed
up yeah I got my own camera over there
so I'm sure the food haha hungry you
might not really home got a moment since
you sang with the Raptors again that's
something special for Canada
right so today I made pudding with fish
I oh my god do you ever put it before
no I heard of it but I never took it oh
man oh it doesn't look
do you cook it yeah it's like oh don't
tell me you don't used to eat fish in
Africa no I'm real picky either let try
the fish I put that's right tell me what
do you think you're not eating this a
high one you get so quiet here man
everybody
[Music]
like okay you from Africa in worst
that's got you over there I'm sorry but
[Music]
this is the real regional man talking
the original man eat this hi all right
okay one more um I can't possibly die
from this
[Applause]
he's nobody honey please head to you
she's like 40 percent you know it's not
cooked it's cooked
yes you did what you put it is it like
salt and pepper
you know what do you know your favorite
ingredient this is spicy and fun that we
found out he's fully person no make sure
you get that thank you
oh my god this is actually yeah I didn't
[Music]
believe a statue is ready in the
mid-season cookies I uh Fred Karl I love
you guys I love you guys don't bite me
like I love your mello Yello
now you fool your killer